so well I know that the previous battles inside of
the Tokyo Colony were pure fire however we are now
flying over to another colony where the battles
have escalated far far quicker quickly surpassing
the brutality of Tokyo turned in the bustling
city of Sendai into a domain of pure viciousness
just before we do get into the video though if you
are new around here and want to watch more content
just like this where I go over a bunch of arcs and
fights from throughout a bunch of different series
then make sure you hit that subscribe button
and also be sure to leave a like on the video
as it really helps out with pushing my content
to a bunch of new amazing people so yes just
like I previously mentioned we have now left the
Tokyo Colony number one with Yuji and megumi are
to fly over to Gege's other main character they
no longer depressed Yuta Okkots who's currently
in the Sendai Colony there are currently four
powerhouses at the center of the conflict and
just like the Tokyo Colony Cinder here has also
reached a deadlock due to only the PowerHouse has
been left over druve lukdewala is a veteran of
the Civil War of War a war in which it was like
literally him versus everyone else so the dude
must have been pure Insanity it's explain that
he currently sits at 91 points and has the ability
to use two kinds of independent shikigami that can
compose a domain with their like orbiting thingies
somewhere else inside of the Sendai Colony we find
a damn JoJo character under the name of Ryu
Ishigori this man currently sits at 77 points
and has the highest curse energy output of all
of the players in the Cullen game so like does he
even surpass Yoda perhaps anyway shooting over to
another Powerhouse called Takako Uro as explained
that this babe of a character is the former
captain of the sun moon and star Squad who are
a group of deadly assassins directly affiliated
with a fujiwara clan what you now own will the
fujiwara clan prospered for around 1200 years from
the 600s dominating the Imperial Court until 1868.
so gigabin Giga has probably taken her directly
from a specific time period throughout those 1200
years and assuming she's insanely strong it was
probably during the golden period or the hean
period of 794 through 1185 where they held most
of their dominance in the court anyways skipping
over to this bug who kuroshi which is a special
grade cockroach curse that kinjaku had released
from kiddo's curse Spirit manipulation and it was
probably one of those like very few special grade
Skittles keeping hidden during the night parade
let's explain that it currently has 54 points and
is lined dormant until the unfavorable conditions
disappear due to the conflicting abilities in
Natures the four powerhouses Force the standoff
rather than Alliance however they did lock falls
apart when one side eventually collapses Drew luck
to Wyler you said old school fart is cut down by
Tokyo Jiu Jitsu highs infamous second year student
Yuta akotsu who now has 35 points so like man has
literally become demon mode throughout this part
of the story remember how he had also lost his
uh ranking after the end of jjk zero well it's
explained here that he reclaimed his rank three
months after the night parade of a hundred demons
and still possesses unusual strength second only
to saturno Gojo so the hype for this battle is
absolutely insane right now takako and Ryu who
are nearby observe the developing situation and
the simdai colony due to himself to reflect a
while has fallen and is patrolling shikigami are
disappearing Ryu uses his cocaine to check who
defeated dhruv and discovers the player as due
to akotsu takaku does the same and while she's
glad the ugly shikagami are disappearing she's
concerned about a new threat that will surely
emerge back with Ryu he realizes that he was only
able to get close to Drew without provoking him
before because he was occupied in battle with
you to these two new Sorcerers both know that
following Drew's defeat kuroroshi will likely
emerge next back over with our boy though after
cutting down truth he regroups with a crowd of
civilians he's been protecting he tells them
that it's time to head north at the edge of
the barrier but notices a mother and daughter
struggling to go on because of this he changes
his mind and tells all of the civilians they can
rest and settle the stadium that will serve in his
Drew's base suddenly though he's interrupted by a
buzzing and collectoring sound that indicates some
sort of danger due to immediately orders everyone
to hurry inside of the stadium and he draws his
Katana he looks out and sees an overwhelming swarm
of cockroach approaches chasing people it's funny
like cutting myself off for a second you know it's
like a mega miguji Fusion like The Best of Both
Worlds man will murk anyone when necessary and
also save the helpless as much as possible anyways
anyways ljjk Hannah Montana jumps fourth thinking
he can save the remaining man but as you to grabs
the man's arm he's unable to pull him away in time
and sadly the Cockroaches Devour the civilian's
lower body then as the Cockroaches jump from the
man's body to attack you to quickly blocks with
his Katana and notices that all of the bugs are
indeed real and sex reinforced with curse energy
the Swarm attempts to rush past Utah to Ravish
the other civilians but he summons Rika to stop
them the Demonic Powerhouse himself then uses
that curse devil IQ and smashes down on a bridge
collecting the structure on top of the Swarm
forcing it to go back towards Utah the special
grade sorcerer then abused his Katana with curse
energy and swings it with enough Force to create
a large blast of cursed energy that disintegrates
the whole swarm in one shot watching the action
from afar Ryu comments that while you just cursed
energy output isn't anything special his overall
Coast Energy manipulation is extremely impressive
also observing tsukaku outro states that Utah's
overall curse energy is bottomless and that the
Cockroach curses are disgusting so this elbargo
it's explained that he was a poor matchup for
drove so to play things safe it went into like
a dormant space until droof was eliminated the
curse has an endless appetite and 18 stimulates
its ability to perform parthenogenesis which
and our monkey bring terms and that took me five
times to say just means This creepy old bug can
self-reproduce not needing a male or female
partner now awakened the Cockroach curse is
starving and its instincts immediately lead it
to devour YouTube while preparing the face off
against kuroroshi yudapondus his objective in
this Colony he knows his resources are finite
and it's only a matter of time before overall
allowing passage in and out of colonies is
added however dangerous players like truth
can't be allowed to leave the barrier either
with the likelihood that there are other
players just like him usually knows that
communication between colonies is necessary to
prevent anyone dangerous from leaving their game
in addition to the roles Megami proposed in the
meeting with tingen Utah understands his allies
need a means of communication and a way to move
in and out of the colonies so in total that's
four rules the group needs to create to get a
handle on the culling game which is actually
insane because that's at least 400 points or
a majority of the reincarnations kinjaku has
actually brought back anyways Yuda feels that
the Shibuya incident exhausted all of his allies
and he doesn't want to make his sense a Killer's
best friend again poised and ready to engage the
enemy player with his Katana usually resolves
to kill kinjaku and obtain 400 points all on
his own so let the absolute bloodbath begin
noticing yuda's battle starts kuroshi bulks
up and reveals a curse talk called the festering
life sword an enchanted blade that mixes life and
death itself armed with the festering life sword
kuroroshi ferociously attacks only to have his
arm immediately cut off by Utah the sorcerer then
uses his Katana to pin the kusa's arm to a rock
literally just to harming it by turning the arm
into a freaking barbecue sword skewer you didn't
pulls up with a dead level backhand strike that
since kuroroshi's getting back across the water
the Cockroach curse tries to fly up above the
bridge but Yuda who's just too damn quick jumps
on top of the bridge first then grabs and flings
a piece of railing that hits kuroroshi in the
chest taking this moment Yoda capitalizes on the
opening he created by sending kuroroshi down and
to the water below with a sick diving slash as
the water clears though it's revealed that the
curse managed to stop juda's blade by using a
swarm of cockroaches Yuda swipes the storm away
with a sword while kuroroshi manipulates his bugs
into a twister of cockroaches to malevently stand
on below uturas are weird that he's been watched
by the two other players with high scores he
knows he can easily exercise kuroshi by driving
reverse Coast energy into his body in a similar
fashion to how we revived Yuji in their fight
however Yuna doesn't want the observing players
to see that he can use a reverse curse technique
additionally he can't call Enrique because she's
protecting everyone else at the stadium kuroroshi
is indeed a dangerous opponent but Yuda wants to
exercise her without relying on either of his two
backup techniques out of nowhere though this bug
somehow manages to speak which you know actually
makes sense is over time special grades can like
easily develop a language anyways it asks you to
why he's interfering with his feeding referring to
her not letting her Munch down on those civilians
back there to a tutor responds by asking the curse
white kills people and kuroroshi simply replies
that it likes the taste of iron then going on to
chart binding over and over again kuroshi uses
its Earthen insect trance technique to summon
small and seek like curses that carry these
unproportionate looking nut texts with them
instantly a swarm of cockroaches shoot down and
around UDA forcing him to stab the shallow water
below him to create a shock wave allowing him
to hide once this swarm dissipates the curses
from kuroroshi's previous technique attack user
from behind you just slashes them apart but sadly
the toxins from their big ass sex blind him for
a moment giving kuroshi an opening the Cockroach
curse retrieves the first three life sword and
slashes at his Target Judo manages to block with
his katana but the festering life sword shoot
something into his shoulder as a boy darts back
he figured that the curse tool might be able
to shoot projectiles but he instantly realizes
something's wrong and more insect-like curses
suddenly grow out of his shoulder wound taken
by surprise Yuna tries to cut them off with his
Katana but this gives kuroroshi another opening
to attack closing in the Cockroach curse slashes
Yuta across his abdomen opening up another wound
and causing more curses to spawn from it Ryu and
takako watching shock as kuroroshi then grabs you
at his body fully expecting her to devour him yusu
though plays the infamous Uno reversal and grabs
the cursor's face before sinking his teeth into
kuroroshi's exoskeleton then as he's munching down
he drives a reverse curse energy blast through
his teeth into the Cockroach compromising the
Integrity of its body and exercising the special
grade curse kuroshi Falls to Paces while you just
spit its remains onto the ground earning himself
another five points from kogane where the curse
Spirit out of the way and Utah in a vulnerable
state uru decides to take advantage of situation
and confronts them directly levitating upside down
behind a new rival or her Whispers into juda's ear
taking him by surprise before you can confront the
danger directly though or reduces the dopas curse
technique to heavily distort the space around them
instantly this Distortion fractures the terrain
around her and launches you to backwards taking
the hit head-on you know minimizes the damage and
starts to wonder how exactly she caused so much
destruction but before he has time to think Oro
follows up her attack with a punch Yuda is just
able to weave past the hit and tries to counter
with a punch of his own however Oro grips down
and warps the sky around his fist completely
stopping his counter-attack and turning his hand
into some spaghetti ass noodle which like reminds
me of Harry's hand over the Quidditch game and
Chamber of Secrets anyways anyways while you just
stands the confused by his distorted appendage
Ro knocks him back with another attack now out
of combat yuda's arm quickly returns to normal
without any damage leading Juda to assume Ora's
curse technique manipulates space without actually
crushing anything within it similar to how like
a lens crest abortion that's just an idea but
I I wonder if she could also create some sort
of pocket Dimension or Wormhole hear me out it
does sound kind of crazy but as you could grab
two specific points in space and distort those
points to make them touch technically that's how
we think a wormhole might work over a 3D plane
and from that it opens up this series too late
the idea of time travel or a high domain like
the fourth dimension or something anyways you
know it sounds a bit bizarre the reason I say
this is because uru discloses her ability right
now and reveals her curse technique treats the
sky as a surface for example era can physically
grab an open space making it a tangible object
which in turn allows you to manipulate it as if
it was some sort of curtain both of the previous
attacks on Utah bypasses defenses and scent of
flying so he figures that there must be some sort
of tractor ability if warped surfaces are able to
accomplish that impatiently uru waits for opponent
to attack so she can counter with her technique
but instead Judah asks her a question he asks if
a roe wouldn't complain if she were to be killed
and why exactly she's seeking out conflict he
understands that powerless people get desperate
but this doesn't apply to uro because her curse
technique makes it such a formidable opponent
compared to the majority of other sorcerers in the
culling game uro explains to him that she doesn't
take receiving a new body lightly as essentially
incarnated Sorcerers have returned from the shadow
realm she feels like someone without regret
wouldn't have joined the killing game in the
first place so as the first step in her new life
she has prioritizing points and that's why she's
attacking still confused probably even like more
than us reading right now because it made no sense
to me what she said there Judah asks if uro has
a lover or a companion she's fighting for the
reason he asks this is because he simply can't
understand why someone would spend time killing
people thousands of years later even if they have
regrets listening to you to play but on though uru
gets more and more pissed off all culminating
at the point where Yuda asks her how she could
possibly be so desperate that she'd only return
for her own selfish game I write and literally
blowing blood vessels on a dome Oru asks a
future as a descendant of the fujiwara clan
claiming that someone of his blood wouldn't ever
understand her which I don't think he is he's a
michizani's descendant so I don't think that's
fujiwara someone let me know down in the comment
section below Ryu though remember that like random
apparently op JoJo's character from before well
his ass interrupts the conversation by using
his insane Granite blast to far a massive wave
of cursed energy from his head at both players
leaving the previously beautiful city now just
a pile of rubble having attacked from a nearby
rooftop Ryu claims Yuta and Urus fluorescene is
making him hungry for battle era decides that
there's no reason to let Ryu go now now that
the colonies did look is broken use it in uru
simultaneously decide it's time to take Ryu out
they both Dash in straight towards Ryu exciting
the long-range fighter who responds with a volley
of cursed energy beams their weave after the
approaching Fighters Yuna is narrowly able
to avoid the initial barrage using his agility
but a second wave of attacks appears to take him
off guard decimating him and the bridge he's
standing on however once the Smoke Clears for
you who thought he landed a direct hit notices
that Yuda is gone suddenly Judah leaps up from
behind onto the roof to confront Rio directly
forcing him to realize that you'd use the whole
Rica made in the bridge to avoid the beams and
get out of sights having successfully closed the
distance between them Yuna attacks the ancient
sorcerer directly before darting back into his
fighting pose and declaring that it's time to
bring the fight into a close range amused by
yuda's display of skill Ryu asks if fighting up
close will satisfy his hunger elaborating on his
comment Ryu asks if someone should tell a child
in front of her face to calm down and eat slowly
Yuda suggests that someone should do that and Ryu
actually agrees admitting that it was probably a
bad example lighting up a city Ryu says he didn't
have any major regrets in his first life where he
fought worthy opponents and had met a good
woman even so he still suffers from a thirst
that no one understands and because of that he's
still unsatisfied he says that cigarettes have a
sweet aftertaste but his life has never had that
kind of dessert instantly Ryu unleashes a flowery
of attacks causing you to quickly respond with
punches of his own giving them both a chance to
feel for each other's combat prowess Judah notes
that Ryu has an explosive cursed energy output
combined with very precise and quick movements
even without his Advanced toughness a direct
hit from Ryu would cause significant damage
after exchanging several blows and parrying
one another both Fighters turn to land a spinning
attack however Ryu clashes his back against Utah
and expels a blast of cursed energy that sends the
letter flying back off the roof due to crashes to
the top of another building losing his footing for
a moment but quickly manages to regain his balance
immediately where you heavy notices stumble
follows up with another Granite blast attack
sitting in a beam of energy directly at user but
somehow you're just able to deflect it with his
bare freaking hands like some Harry Potter spell
without a one level of holy [__] then Yoda in a
damn flash quickly closes the distance and tries
to crush his opponent with a fierce right hook to
the Dome crushing Ryu into the roof and cracking
the concrete floor below him however it actually
seems that Ryu had condom into a false sense of
security as he counters with another beam of curse
energy that Utah is unable to fully overpower as
he blasts you to back where you tells him that you
are my desert Euro who's like just rolled up on
the scene takes advantage of yuda's unfavorable
positioning in mid-air and targets him with a
curse technique let's explain that technically
she doesn't hit the person with her technique
but strikes the surface of the sky and steered
having revealed the extent of your Technique or it
breaks the surface like thin ice and smacks your
opponent straight down onto the brick road below
irritated by the interference where you shoot a
wave of curse energy at uro and tells her that
she's in his way telling him to silence himself
though Oru uses her technique to warp the space
around the cursed energy beam firing it right back
at him and hitting him directly injured yuruthin
manages to return to the battlefield which amuses
uro who claims it's great that he's tough as she's
going to toy with him eljojo wannabe who's still
recovering from his own attack notices that Yoda
is constantly using his reverse curse technique
to heal himself and using up all of his near
bottom curse energy leaped down by his opponent's
receding strength Ryu comes to the conclusion that
Yuda is not the dessert he had been searching for
to quench his gluttonous thirst thinking on what
to do himself Judah knows that Ryu doesn't Target
civilians but he wouldn't care if they ended up as
collateral damage in an attack Judo knows that he
wanted to put more distance between fighting and
the stadium where the civilians are just in case
but that isn't likely to happen anymore instead
Judah decides to use his full strength now he
pulls out and puts on his ring then kills upon
Riker and asks her to give him everything Rick
is suddenly manifest as a curse Spirit right next
to him leaving both Ryu and uro confused by this
tune of events we're always shocked Yeti wasn't
already using his full power and Ryu doesn't
understand how yuda's curse energy is already
filling back up for those of you like confused
think of Rika like a water tank of cursed energy
and when Yoda decides to open that tap he can
just refill his deflated curse energy on top of
that break your tears open a chest to display a
freaking arsenal of cursed tools kept inside her
body for you to choose from so rake of the curse
is technically different to Riker orimoto and once
the young child's spirit peacefully passed away at
the end of jjk zero the cursed Spirit itself
stayed directly connected to yuda's ring and
while the connection is active Reika is capable
of storing curse energy for Yuta completing her
full manifestation to Aid him in battle and can
even Supply cursed talks for him though he can
only maintain the sustained connection for up
to like five minutes having chosen the missile
arm Rika attaches the casing around yudu's right
arm to improve his overall striking power ready
to re-engage in the now three-way battle Yoda
Begins by having Rika saw through the air towards
Arrow who now prepares who Sky manipulation
technique and response however Utah suddenly
create superlific snake eyes and fangs schedule
of the inumahi clan on his mouth and activates
cursed speech commanding all of his opponents to
not move Oru tries to cover her ears but she's
just too late and is immediately immobilized
which I wonder if that implies that the inumaki
clan had been around from the time that uru was
previously alive as she reacts like she knew what
the ability was anyways unable to defend herself
Aura was pummeled by a large barrage of strikes
from both Yuta and reiker since shooting off Jose
then drops down and launches himself off wreck
his arms like he's a goddamn volleyball towards
uro continuing to pressure her for you tries to
intervene in their fight and launches a beam of
cursed energy claiming that Yoda's approach is
too soft Ricky though cuts it off and slices the
attack in half with one hand and pressing Ryu who
believes that Riku might be even more durable than
uter himself irritated by the pain Rika angrily
lashes out punching Ryu in the face and sending
him flying off their roof he tries to follow up
with another strike but Ryu quickly counters with
an explosive punch of his own smashing Rika back
into the roof of an opposing building excited
with the potential to satisfy his hunger Ryu
fixes his hair and claims he has an appetite that
calls for an extra large helping back with the
other two though you just summons a bunch of small
flying shikigami by using strains of his hair as
an intermediary uru destroys one of them using new
technique and claims that members of the fujiwara
are only standing away because they fear her true
potential going on that typical anime level Spiel
she explains that she is the leader of his sun
moon and star squads Affiliated directly with the
tour of the fujiwara clan there were assassins
that pursued lives or selfless devotion and the
shadows and didn't even be names a particular
Sorcerer of the fujiwara clan though gave takako
her name only to execute her as a proxy to cover
up his own crimes of killing someone else and
the clan suddenly though Ura was cut off from its
sentence and cut across her chest and herps by the
shikigami those trajectories are the shikigami
constitute o domain which uru immediately
recognizes as Drew's technique remember like that
old man from the very beginning of the fight she
realizes that Judah isn't a cursed speech user
with the ability to summon shikigami instead he's
a sorcerer with the ability to copy others curse
techniques Yuda proceeds to follow up and knocks
uru down to where Ryu and Rika are fighting he
tries to capitalize with a straight punch but uro
manages to stop his attack and break his armored
shell with the Icebreaker effect of your Technique
uninjured by this exchange though you details
uro that regardless of what his ancestors may
have done living for herself will only get her so
far yet those words just hit a complete block and
only served to further annoy uro who claimed that
saying things like live for others is something
only those who have achieved something can do the
conversation is interrupted though when they both
notice a massive search and reuse curse energy
Ryu thinks his opponents need to shut up because
words are utterly pointless at this stage of
the fights are you guys already as the three
of them suddenly look at each other prepare to
bring their three-way battle to a climax the
trio of sindo's strongest sorceress all activate
their domain expansion simultaneously instantly
and like because of the three overlapping domains
they cancel each other's short hit functions out
without that Advantage for you and uro know
that they need to stop yosa from taking the
initiative by keeping Reika out of the barrier
Ryu knows that he had already knocked Rika over
20 meters away so it was unlikely you'd be able
to reach the barrier in time but outside it's
shown that the last vestiges of Rika or imoto's
will inside of Rika couldn't accept that she was
unable to protect Yuta causing her strength to
wretch it up another notch suddenly kuroroshi
yes remember that damn cockroach from back at the
beginning of the video that just got milk by user
randomly appears and infiltrates the freaking
barrier while it's cockroaches outside occupy
recur so remember how I said this dude was able
to self-reproduce and all that kind of stuff well
before going dormant kuroshi actually reproduced
via his parthenogenesis after Judah exercised the
parent roach the country's curse energy of fear
was transferred into the new Offspring kuroshi
the player is indeed perished but kuroroshi
the curse spirit is still completely active
three overlapping domains are more complex
than two and the conditions imbued within
their barriers complicate things even further
with the addition of an unexpected Intruder
the barriers are completely compromised
and begin to shatter falling to paces
falling out themselves Yuna notices that uro is
totally focused on kuroroshi obviously this is due
to her technique being at a complete disadvantage
with the roach because of this Yuna takes the
opportunity and literally kicks uro in the back
while she's distracted sending her flying towards
the ground almost like cementing her death seeing
her coming down the cursed roach rushes towards
her with the festering life sword uru tries
to respond by activating her curse technique
however as we all know from the past events with
mojito curse techniques are difficult to use
immediately after using a domain expansion and
uru's ability to manipulate space Burns away in
her hands leaving it open takura Roshi's assault
the roach curse slashes uro's left arm and quickly
these disgusting and sick-like curses spawn funny
wound severing her limb completely Rika who's also
there acts quickly by devouring uro's arm before
the roach code and pressing Ryu he notes that
Yuda is thorough and that it's unlikely that uro
can regenerate her entire arm even if she uses a
reverse curse technique I write over the loss of
her arm root angrily calls out to The fujiwara
Descendant cutting her off though Ryu tells her
to stop because she and kuroshi uninvited to his
table yes if you have noticed everything to do
with Ryu ishiguri has something to do with eating
food like the dessert thing from earlier or now
the whole like you ain't invited to this table
you can't eat from this table type thing anyway
anyway let's explain that ryu's curse technique is
called cursed energy discharge and he's the only
sorcerer capable of outputting the same amount of
power regardless of if his technique is active
or not instantly he blasts uro and Karoshi with
another jacked up Granite blast incapacitating
Euro and partially destroying kuroroshi making it
simple for you to exercise with his reverse curse
energy excited for his dessert now Ryu fixes his
drip and welcomes Yuta to the table he charges his
cursed energy and takes aim while opposite him you
don't know that his own curse technique has yet
to replenish but with Yusuf and Riker working
together to counter the ancient sorcerer as the
next move the table is set for the final battle as
line that you can only unleash a direct beam of
cursed energy while Rika is completely manifested
even at full power Judas blasts are slightly
weaker than reuse in order to win The Exchange
Yoda intends on a rapidly building up cursed
energy and firing first before Ryu reaches
maximum power however ryu's Eyes Express over
400 years of hunger waiting to be satiated and
his gaze pleads with Yuta to use his full power
although Utah would never find true meaning and
conflict reuse gaze melted his heart melted my
damn heart as well look at those eyes it's so
damn beautiful anyways Yuda agrees to go all out
on this just once and both Sorcerers Unleashed
their curse energy the blasts Collide and they
curse energy beam struggle that's extremely
reminiscent of an old-school DBZ Blast Off sadly
though Yuda is quickly overpowered by ryu's blast
the duo are seemingly hit and sent back into a
nearby building which Ryu immediately expresses
How Sweet the first taste of his dessert was the
gleeful sorcerer is quickly surprised though when
when he begins to feel his opponent's cursed
energy swelling up wanting a male he desires
he screams in us for another being struggle and
retaliation rikifies a blast of cursed energy
while Utah simultaneously rushes forward it's
showing that Yoda actually jumped forward at the
exact same time the blast hurt launching him at
high speed towards the enemy sorcerer breaker is
also able to shoot completely on her own but Ryu
believes he's jacked enough and somehow he blocks
The Beam with his spear hands as well claiming
that he can do whatever you to can he takes aim
at quta and expects to finish him off with his
next attack due to the cursed energy he extended
on top of just using a domain expansion however as
his Granite blast shoots out an unbeknownst to Ryu
yudhas technique had already replenished he takes
this moment and uses oru's ability to warp space
redirecting ryu's blast up into the ear shocked
where you realizes tayuda can actually copy
people's curse techniques and tries to symbolize
what condition he must fulfill to do so he recalls
Riker devouring uru's arm and figures that there
must have been when he satiated the condition yuru
notices ryu's lack of focus capitalizing on it
and scores a direct hit to ryu's chest with oro's
thin Icebreaker move quickly he follows up with
another combination downward punch using Riker
that hits so hard it causes Ryu to become bleeding
profusely from his head so I remember how there
was like a time limit on rika's manifestation well
five minutes have now passed since you to donned
his ring causing the connection between him and
Rick is actually in Ryu takes advantage of this
by hitting Riker with his full power an attack
that was too much for her to handle even more
fully manifested because of this Reiki quickly
reaches the limit and disappears from the battle
leaving Utah to continue fighting on his own the
big man himself Ryu is excited that there's even
more to their battle even after clashing at full
power he happily declares that this final course
is the dessert he has been longing for standing
there you do surprises the Ancient One by grabbing
him with both hands and pushing their weight down
so hard that it cracks the ground Beneath Your
Feet after effectively immobilizing them both
Judah claimed that the fight is over confusing
Ryu while shigori is looking down at the cracked
ground his Granite Blast from earlier yes remember
that one Juda shot up into the sky using Uro's
technique well it rains down to rexley on Ryu
and surprises the unsuspecting sorcerer completely
toasting him still standing there though like like
an actual champion but still defeated where you
quickly realizes that he was just hit by his own
beam as Judah redirected it back down using Uro's
technique at the same time Ricard hurt him despite
his defeat for he was satisfied with the high
level of battle he participated in and thanks
you sir now that his stomach is finally full not
gonna lie getting those the terminology of this
saying so damn well and we all just ate as well as
Ryu Ishigori did right here boys anyways anyways
following the end of the battle in the Sendai
Colony you're the first talks to the defeated
Uro in order to retrieve her points she tells
you to this like extremely ominous statement
they probably will 100 play a role later on in
the story she says that his strength has a limit
and she's seen a power beyond the Horizon of the
strongest Fighters and curses with their very own
eyes in that moment she imagines Sukuna's original
form and claims that such power takes the form of
overwhelming a Christian that disregards anything
else like a Calamity Yuta then moves on to Ryu who
tells him that he's too soft and he won't receive
praise for his actions he'd replies to him though
that Takako also told him something similar that
there was no value in sparing an opponent's life
having heard this for you were surprised to learn
that uru survived and believes his blast must have
been weakened after using domain expansion which
like I brought up earlier makes sense as most of
the time after using a domain someone's technique
will slightly falter in comparison to before the
domain was used anyways anyways Ryu sits up and
asks what uru kept getting upset about during
the fight and asks if it was a lover's quarrel
you'd try splitting him off but after persisting
explains that anything he could have said to
her would have just led to violence because he's
blessed Ryu doesn't really understand what you
don't mean by this but still respects his words
after a brief break our man decides to get back
on his mission and asks Ryu to hand over all of
his points the ancient sorcerer is like kind of
initially confused by uh what he means about this
but cocaine explains that a new rule was added a
while back that allows players to transfer points
to one another Ryu believes he understands that's
why you suspend their lives now but still asks if
he would have killed them without their rule Yuta
suggests that it definitely was a possibility and
smiles while telling Ryu to just be grateful
to his new comrade which you know could be uh
interesting with that little comment there for
what could happen in the future little use of
Ryu tag team like Duo anyway thanks to the point
transfers from uro and Ryu on top of the points
he already gained from a lemon 18 dwarf and
Kurourushi Yuta now has a total of 200 points
putting him at the halfway points and their plan
to bring down the culling game so that officially
brings us to the end of this like Arc here or
the smaller Arc and the next jjk Arc we're going
back over to the Tokyo Colony or the second Tokyo
colony to get some of the craziest freaking hands
you have ever saying with Kashima versus zakari
like it's actually so freaking brutal but so damn
good if you want to get earlier access to these
videos and possibly other contents like in the
future that I won't release on YouTube you can
check out my patreon which I will leave down in
the description below and if you guys like this
video and want to watch more content just like
it then make sure you hit the Subscribe button
and also be sure to leave a like on the video as
it really helps out with pushing my content to a
bunch of new amazing people but anyway enough of
that Vanessa being a professional did you know
it dear Volo and I will see you all enable bye